Harry is with us in Chicago hi Carrie
how are you hi I'm good
good how can I help okay
I'm very young and my husband I got
married last July in 2015
well Piazza del fifteen and we worked at
Bridal exposed and you know how you
write your name down and basically all
you come in a presentation well we did
that we were very seated about that and
now I reject that because you know we
got a phone call saying I'll check out
our resort it's only nine minutes so we
did that with my my in-laws and they
were not let's leave and separate being
90 minutes we were there for even half
hours it would have so much they didn't
a lot of make a decision ourselves and
I'm one I'm one percent out of the 95 or
97 percent that does not like timeshares
non-specialists timeshare and we did pay
someone to try getting us out of it and
now we're at the point where were 134
days to one foot what we haven't made
famous because a third lawyer told us to
do and I called the time shared after
that option course and they said that we
could either pay you know and sustain
the account and put the payments are
gonna sit same or before close it
oh my I'm just seeking advice like what
should we do because we were 18 I barely
had a job and I thought I tried to tell
them that but they didn't listen to us
and we were well no wait a minute
women on this you were 18 and yet you
didn't have the emotional energy and
character to simply say no but you
cannot blame this on them you signed up
for it I know so I know they're going
off the blame but us yeah I was very
educated exactly and you know you walked
into a bear trap and you got bit by the
bear you know yeah and so what you learn
from this is though that you know you
they didn't have a gun they kept you
three and a half hours when you just get
your butt up and walk out of there oh
you're late in half but usually in there
and a half hours what's wrong why would
you do that
I know they kept bringing other people
up I know why didn't you just get up and
say stick it in your ear I'm walking out
of here I want to sit there eight and a
half I want to sit anywhere hours for
anything I know it was just a big mess
no it's the lesson I want you to take
away that's why I'm leaning in on you is
that you can you can have to this is
painful for you but you have to make
sure that you always retain your ability
to walk away from something at any
moment and tell somebody stick it in
their ear okay yeah I learned that the
hard way
now here's what you do you call time
share exit team time yeah I actually
have like my grandparents recommend me
you know the time travel rotator that's
the only way I know for you to get out
of this okay
have you already done a deal with them
oh well they they gave us a quote there
was $8,500 and we couldn't afford it
okay so we we can move on with someone
and the very discloser does yeah and
they're not doing their job
yeah the only one I've ever found that
actually pulls this off this timeshare
exit team and it can be expensive but
hold on the stupid timeshare is going to
be expensive and get foreclosed on is
going to be expensive too so that's the
only way I know to get you out of it
they're absolutely timeshares aren't
absolute horrendous the industry is I
mean what a bunch of jerks it set an 18
year old kid in a room and hold them in
there for eight and a half hours I mean
what kind of [ __ ] does something like
that well that's the scum that are in
the timeshare business and who does
something like that so you ought to be
ashamed of yourself if you're in that
business doing that kind of stuff that's
just horrible but you know and basically
timeshare exit team can get you out
honey that's the only way I know to get
out and so you need to save up the money
and be able to pull that off and that
that's if I were in your shoes that's
what I would do hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
down
[Music]